alors tout ce que j'ai à vous dire je
vous le dis ramè les sous demain du coup
vous allez perdre votre Paris une fois
de plus j'avis l'air sûr de vous un bou
le fric je suis très sûr de
moi je le dis voilà il y a une lo il y a
une loi il vient d' prendre une lo je te
le dis il y a une loi ramène 100 €
demain texli tu eu l'info c'est fini tu
tu es cuit voilà tu vas perdre ton Paris
voilà une fois de plus tu es encore à
côté de la Cup Carla Moro sous influence
elle est là Carla et elle est là elle
est là elle est là bim BIM vous êtes la
fille de Daniel morou
non
c'est rayon qui me posait la
question il y a beaucoup de Moro euh oui
c'est vrai beaucoup de Mor exactement
oui 2 minutes je suis en clientèle je
suis à vous dans un instant il y a
beaucoup de gens qui reparlent encore et
c'est vrai ce livre c'est bien que tu
car là que tu reviennes sur la
sorcellerie c'est c'est parce que j'ai
les infos tu vois je vois les infos sur
ton livre cette histoire t'a coûté plus
de 2 million d'euros 2 millions d'euros
ou c'est une histoire de fou comment tu
as fait aujourd'hui tu reste des sous ou
bien comment tu as fait bien évidemment
que je continue l'influence et que je
travaille en parallèle de l'influence he
2 millions d'euros c'est c'est c'est
c'est mais effectivement c'est une sacré
somme c'esti non mais sans rigolé c'est
un truc de fou en avril dernier c'est
vrai qu'il y a huit hommes qui sont
venus t'intimider chez toi que tu dis
dans le livre également ou-ce qu'ils
t'ont dit comment qu'est-ce qu'
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait pour
t'intimider ils ont essayer de pénétrer
dans ma maison armée ouais et et
heureusement que la police a intervenu
pour justement heureusement que j'avais
des alarmes nécessaire et c'est comme ça
que j'ai décidé de de prendre une
personne pour pour ma sécurité à partir
de maintenant euh là là tu es tout le
temps avec quelqu'un en sécurité à la
maison oui ah d'accord ah
ouais comme tu n dit tu as commencé là à
18 ans ton père tu as une enfance très
compliquée dur ta maman tu as eu très
jeune à quel âge tu es à 20 ans 20 ans
et ton père tu dis était alcoolique il
éta tu étais en TR tremballer
d'appartement en appartement donc
aujourd'hui tu étais content de de t'en
sortir avec avec tout ça avec ah ben
bien sûr que je suis contente de m'en
sortir avec tout ce que j'ai pu
vivre bien évidemment maintenant que
j'ai la maturité nécessaire
effectivement quand quand on parle de
Somme pareil je m'en veux et je regrette
et j'aurais voulu réagir beaucoup plus
rapidement et prendre cette prise de
conscience enfin de de conscience avant
mais j'y arrivais pas parce que quand on
est sous emprise on le comprend pas mais
on peut faire beaucoup de choses sous
emprise c'est exactement ce que j'ai
fait les vidéos on a fait une compile de
la sorcellerie et G revenir là-dessus
avant dearler de de Gérard par c'est
parti par cette présenté par Kevin gate
je demande que tu n'auras aucune pensée
sexuelle ni cune envie de déjà de te
braner ou de te toucher par aucune autre
femme que moi donc ça c'est le sucre
imbibé du sang des règles de Carla Carla
lui dit quoi c'est mieux avec du jus de
fruits plus il y a de sang mieux c'est
c'est de ouf en premier je pique Maeva
pour que Maeva quitte définitivement W9
et la production et que Carla redevienne
à tout jamais la première des candidates
de télé les Marseillais
oui alors l'histoire des vidéos est
incroyable en tout il y a 200 vidéos et
les trois premières sont faites par
Carla c'estàd qu'il y a trois vidéosil à
mon ins oui voilà vous le faites elle
vous filme à votre insie mais après la
voyante qui va être aidée par des gens
va créer des vidéos en faisant croire
que c'est Carla qui fait la vidéo
c'estàd qu'elle va imiter votre voix
elle va même mettre une main en disant
que c'est vous c'est ça elle va voler V
elle me manipulit de manière à ce que
moi au départ j'y vais pour bah
forcément être amoureuse au départ le le
vrai sujet c'est d'être amoureuse et
d'être aimée par la personne que j'aime
et tout à coup tout a basculé du moment
où déjà je suis devenue connu du moment
où j'ai fait les Marseillais d'ailleurs
je le raconte dans mon livre bien avant
je suis allé voir cette cette voyante
c'était bien avant les Marseillais et là
tout tout de suite ça va engendrer
d'autres choses est-ce que tu vas être
connu est-ce que tu vas être mieux comme
vous par exemple demain quand quand vous
êtes sur ce plateau vous avez envie de
réussir ce que vous faites vous avez
envie d'être le vous avez envie d'être
d'être fort de pouvoir dire des choses
concrètes et intelligentes et c'est vrai
que moi à ce moment-là bien évidemment
que j'ai envie de réussir ma vie bien
évidemment que que que j'ai envie d'être
d'avoir confiance en moi de me sentir
bien et elle va utiliser cette méthode
en se disant mais oui mais si tu tu veux
être heureuse bah ou si tu veux être
bien peut-être qu'il faut éliminer
certaines personnes de ta vie peut-être
que
elles vont déranger le fait que toi tu
évolues de cette manière-là et bêtement
comme je suis sous emprise à ce
moment-là alors que je ne suis
absolument pas comme ça de base dans la
vie tous les jours hors cette
sorcellerie je suis très bienveillante
envers mes amis de tous les jours et
malheureusement il y a il y a ce ce ce
cet engrenage que je n'arrive pas à
contrôler parce que je me retrouve seule
parce que j'ai pas eu une famille pour
m'aider parce que de plus en plus la
voyante me dit de me de me méfier de
tout le monde et comme il y a que elle
qui est au courant de ça bah je me
retrouve seule et je suis dans un
engrenage qui continue qui continue
notamment bah mes péripéties amoureuses
qui Contin continuent à être pas bien et
être malheureuse notamment dans les
premières télés que je fais où je suis
trompée humiliée devant la France
entière c'est difficile
psychologiquement quand tu vis ça et
qu'au départ toi tu as 18 ans et que tu
crois au compte de fait effectivement
que tu te dis pas mon dieu mais mon
chéri il m'a trompé dans la même chambre
à C à côté et je suis je sais pas
comment faire je sais pas comment faire
pour en sortir parce que je l'aime mais
à côté de ça j'ai ça et et cette voyante
elle va avoir une solution à tout une
solution à tous les problèmes comme si
bah c'était une fée une petite fée et
c'est vrai que mine de rien et je le dis
c'est un peu comme un un ticket de
l'auto quand tu joues tu crois pouvoir
gagner ces millions d'euros tu dis si
j'ai si je ce ticket de d'Uros million
bah ou de l'UTO pardon bah je vais
pouvoir m'acheter une maison là une
maison là mais inconsciemment tu le sais
dans ta Tex que ça va pas marcher mais
ces petits moments de bonheur à ce
moment-là où tu as besoin d'amour bah
elle te les procure donc elle est très
forte là-dessus ouis j'ai une question
en fait moi je peux comprendre que du
coup tu te sois fait humil à la télé que
être trompé c'est traumatisant que tu es
désespéré enfin désespéré au point de
mettre du sang dans Les bonbons c'est un
peu bizarre mais c'est quoi cette
histoire alors comment ça histoire de
sang là c'est quoi bah c'est j'ai vu
dans le dans l'extrême et ce que je peux
ce que je comprends pas ce que je
comprends pas c'est comment tu peux
aller loin au point de de de vouloir
évancer tes amis ou les enfants de tes
amisl tu devrais reconnaître que tuas
oup j'ai l'imession les enfants ça n'a
jamais existé premièrement je n'ai
jamais souhaité du mal à des enfants ça
c'est la chose que notamment j'explique
dans mon livre je sais pas si tu l' lu
le livre du coup tu peux pas parler du
coup en connaissance de cause parce que
tu ne sais pas ce qu'il y a dans ce
livre et justement je me justifie
là-dessus je me justifie sur les enfants
je me justifie aussi de la manipulation
que j'ai pu avoir c'était pas notamment
pour souhaiter du mal aux gens céit
uniquement qu'elle me manipulit de cette
manière man manipulé donné il faut
assumer un peu les responsabilités aussi
mais moi j'assumais d'être allé voir
cette voy le dire auss je me suis pas
victimisée depuis le début je dis je
suis allé voir cette VO depuis le début
j'ai dit j'ai voulu croire en l'amour
vise mais moi exle si je suis sous
emprise même si par exemple je suis là
JAC c'est pas forcément mon ami mais je
pas
vouloir non mais je pas vouloir les
vincer voyez ce que je veux dire sûr oui
mais c'est ce que je t'explique par
exemple toi tu env c'est exactement ça
ça prend énormément de forme quand tu es
sous l'emprise et et bien évidemment
quand tu te fais manipuler je pense que
toi-même tu peux le dire tu as été enfin
peut-être influencé à un moment donné
mon livre c'est sous l'influence parce
que on est tous influencé par quel
quelqu'un par sa mère par son conjoint
parce qu'on voit la télé toi-même tu le
dis que tu as eu un passé que maintenant
tu regrettes je me trompe
c'est vrai tu le regrettes parce que tu
étais jeune et parce que tu étais sous
cette influence là moi aussi j'ai été
jeune et moi au lieu de de faire ce que
toi tu as fait bah ça a été la
sorcellerie on a tous des dérives à un
moment donné je défis qui que ce soit de
pas avoir fauté dans sa vie alors il y a
des fautes bien plus graves que d'autres
moi j'en ai payé les frais effectivement
parce que j'ai vécu un calvaire
émotionnel et j'ai vécu aussi un calvire
financier mais c'était mon histoire je
devais peut-être passer par là pour
comprendre certaines choses ce livre
c'est une leçon de vie c'est comprendre
qu'en fait on peut on peut chuter très
bas et se relever et prendre justement
pour les trompris comprendre que tu as
été traumatisé c'est juste pour le côté
amical que bah il faut que tu lives ce
livre et tu comprendras faudrait le lire
merci bah justement Carla sous influence
merci Carla d'avoir été avec nous merci
beaucoupci dire un dernier truc c'est
quoi c'est intéressant oui c'est
pertinent c'est quoi non c'est sur votre
relation avec Kevin parce que quand on
vous voyait dans cette émission vous
étiez solaire vous étiez presque un
couple modèle alors je parle pas des
trom pris dans les émissions on a
l'impression que vous viviez un enfer en
coulisse en fait en réalité c'est
forcément que c'est difficile on peut
pas tout partager sur les réseaux
sociaux et effectivement vous êtes bien
placé pour dire que la vie est pas toute
belle ou toute rose bien évidemment
qu'on a des c'est pas des facettes moi
je je pense que pour faire ce que j'ai
fait je l'ai aimé de tout mon cœur et de
tout tout mon être mais effectivement
que c'était pas tour reuse on n'est pas
le meilleur des couples et d'ailleurs on
l'a montré à plusieurs reprise dans les
tournages que pas tout était parfait
donc je pensais qu'effectivement on en
était sorti bien de cette histoire et
finalement non ça a pas été le cas
puisque puisque nos travers nous ont
rattrapé et certainement que lui aussi
aurait des choses à dire sur moi comme
moi j'en ai à dire sur lui aujourd'hui
je suis pas là pour le dénoncer je suis
là juste pour expliquer mon histoire et
ni pour convaincre les gens d'être de
mon côté je raconte simplement mon
histoire je voulais j'en avait marre
qu'on me juge pour des faits que
personne connaissait réellement
maintenant on pourra me juger pour des
faits qui sont qui sont réels et les
gens qui me suivent depuis le début ben
ils continueront à me suivre et à
comprendre davantage parquoi je suis
passé parce que je m'étais jamais
exprimé je n'ai jamais pris mes réseaux
sociaux pour pouvoir parler de cette
histoire j'avais besoin de prendre
beaucoup plus de temps d'avoir le recul
nécessaire et de le raconter à travers
un livre ça m'a permis de reprendre
confiance en moi et d'expliquer pas à
pas la continuité de ma vie merci parlez
beaucoup hein je suis marseillaise c'est
pour ça au bout de ma vie moi allez
merci euh qu'est-ce qu'il y a est bien
le livre parle bien le livre est super
ouais ouais voilà B oui voilà il est
numéro 1 en plus ou bah tiens suur
merci Carla bravo euh